en primer lugar los indígenas me dijeron
que se sienten desilusionados porque en
Lima un sector de la población lo
desprecia por venir a la capital peruana
protestar también señalaron que se
sienten dolidos porque las fuerzas del
orden los acusan de que los consideran
enemigos y los maltratan esto cuando
ellos me afirman que son ciudadanos con
los mismos derechos los manifestantes en
estos momentos están muy contrariados
porque el parlamento peruano por cuarta
vez ha rechazado el adelanto de
electoral y dicen que ellos no se
sienten representados por este congreso
porque consideran que están desoyendo El
clamor de los diferentes regiones de
Perú que está pidiendo un adelanto
electoral la salida de la presidenta
Dina boluarte la convocatoria a una
asamblea Constituyente y que se redacte
una nueva constitución ellos acusan a
los parlamentarios de estar defendiendo
intereses de grupos de poder porque
señalan que no quieren cambiar el
sistema económico neoliberal que desde
hace 30 años está rigiendo en este país
Francisco qué podemos esperar en
términos de movilizaciones y protestas
para el resto de las jornadas y los días
que vienen
Sí justamente para hoy se está
convocando a una marcha que va a venir
desde los distintos conos de Lima desde
los bordes de la ciudad al centro de la
capital donde van a manifestar
nuevamente su repudio al parlamento
peruano ellos me dijeron que van a
seguir llegando más delegaciones para
protestar en la capital peruana y
también van a ser de énfasis su reclamo
al parlamento y en ese sentido van a
participar también en una jornada
Nacional de protesta que está
programando la confederación general de
trabajadores del Perú la cgtp el próximo
nueve de febrero van a seguir llegando
las manifestaciones de otros lugares del
país y lo que queda en esto es a ver si
de alguna manera el gobierno de Dina
boluarte ejecuta una acción para digamos
que el congreso por fin pueda aprobar lo
que tanto piden los peruanos